il est 15h à bonnel les hommes de la
gendarmerie de saint-arnoult vient
d'autoriser deux camions à repartir ils
avaient été déroutés il hier soir de
l'autoroute
comment dans des situations comme
celle-ci vous en connaissez
régulièrement annoncée des épisodes
neigeux comme celui ci est assez
exceptionnel effectivement puisque mes
gendarmes sont mobilisés depuis hier
environ 15 heures et ont travaillé une
grande partie de la nuit
effectivement pour différentes missions
ça représente combien d'hommes sur le
terrain à peu près alors cette nuit par
exemple où l'épisode neigeux a été le
plus important trente militaires de la
gendarmerie du sud yvelines a travaillé
sur ce secteur il est 15 heures passées
l'assistance peut être véhiculé terminer
quelle est la suite pour vous avec les
températures qui vont baisser cette nuit
où les effectivement la mission est
quasiment rempli mais nous restons
vigilants pour nous sommes toujours
mobilisés bien entendu pour nous assurer
de la viabilité des axes des principaux
axes de communication dans tout le sud
il vit n'est donc même dans tout le
département
les militaires ont effectué une
quinzaine d'interventions depuis le
début de la nuit des interventions
possibles grâce aux agriculteurs aux
communes mais aussi des pompiers comme
ceux de rambouillet
elle y est non vous venez de faire une
intervention que ce qui s'est passé
alors un poids lourd s'est retrouvé
piégé donc sur la commune de rochefort
en yvelines dans une pente
il s'est retrouvé piégé il a glissé
s'est retrouvée bloquée donc contre un
poteau et un arbre en voulant se dégager
le poids lourd a percé son réservoir de
carburant
donc on s'est retrouvé face à un risque
de pollution du reiki et est située
juste de haut niveau du pôle eaux a donc
l'idée de manoeuvre était de pomper le
carburant qui se rester dans le
réservoir environ 700 litres est donc là
on est en attente des pompes pour
réaliser la manoeuvre pour pouvoir
évacuer le poids lourd ensuite sur un
garage poids lourds a dit fais ce temps
là on se doute déjà les pompiers sont
appelés pour de l'assistance à la
personne des voitures qui perdent le
contrôle et ça aussi c'est une mission
peut-être qu'on connaît moins oui alors
là on n'est pas sûr de secours à
personne mais sur deux
plutôt protéger l'environnement d'une
pollution donc c'est qu'il fait partie
intégrante de nos missions puisqu'on est
en campagne donc les délais de route
vu les états de l'état des routes
aujourd'hui est encore augmenté donc
c'est ce qui nous fait perdre énormément
de temps
cette intervention aura duré à la
journée le verglas est attendu pour la
nuit les secours conseille de ne pas
prendre son véhicule